okay yeah take some time think happy
thoughts
[Music]
hi I'm Julie I am from LA California and
I am Mexicans hey I'm David and I'm a
descendant of Mexico hi I'm Alex I was
born in San Diego but I actually grew up
abroad in Singapore I'm Korean Americans
saw be representing Korea hi I'm Lauren
and I'm Korean five six seven eight and
today we're gonna be doing this next lap
I'm very familiar with the Mexican
cuisine cuz I grew up in California so I
think growing up in Asia I really don't
have much experience with much Mexican
snacks or my second scene in general
until I moved here about like five years
ago for college I do I know I have eaten
it before and I know it is amazing what
about Korean barbeque curry k BB q yeah
there we go I have a zero experience and
knowledge about Korean snacks
this is bond Alyssa this is what we call
the Concha it's which means shell it's
like my childhood bread that I like eat
every single week goodbye okay all right
here we go it's so pretty
honestly like all the flavors kind of
taste a little bit the same to me cuz
just like sugar yeah yeah plus a little
flavor e yeah now with this that's good
right yeah this isn't one crazy
everything I mean it's a little bit dry
for some people that's why I like to
like dip it like this or something I
don't know if like that's a Mexican
thing or if that's just a my dad thing
yeah this definitely is like almost the
same thing I think it's got like also
like a layer of stuff on top it's
fantastic and the topping is like it
peels off too so I just used to just
bread yes yeah sugar yes
like what's not to let it go wrong for
me just because I love this growing up I
think I'm just liking the texture this
is just ball that's great this is great
as well not that this isn't good this
son just take take another taking the
bread for me right now I will eat bass
nothing's better than your Abuelita
that's grandma for you know those who
really don't know but this is basically
hot chocolate this is like this is like
the chocolate move but you would like to
see and like every Mexican versus like
pantry Mexican hot chocolate is like a
little bit different than American hot
chocolate like it's a little bit more
bitter but still like sweet overall um
this is kind of like your soulful nutty
warm I don't know how to describe it
Madi and buttery and creamy
yeah this is just like chocolate to the
fullest yeah although those two together
will be kind of good yeah here we go
Cheers right yeah yeah that's good yeah
I mean come on let's bring that Concha
back you can try it's like cinnamon e
cinnamon tea and chocolate that's what
it is it's cinnamon plus chocolate it
has like some kind of like we are rice
flavoring with it it's definitely not
like any any other kind of tea I've
tried before this seems like a healthy
hot chocolate it's just like it's just -
I guess grainy yeah it's very grainy
looking down this would you get this
though probably not are we not but not
because I dislike it I like this one you
know what it is I can't stop drinking it
for me it would also be this one because
it just feels like Christmas
I'm like wrapped in a blanket it's
chatty in front of the fireplace with my
friends I'm gonna have to go without
beneath us this is like the staple stuff
like you can't turn down your Abuelita
like that's sacrilege you smell it I can
it's like this is pretty much like a
fish jerky it's not it's not savory it's
not oily this savory let's not save me
and salty like a chip it definitely
doesn't have the texture of a chip it's
a lot tougher I'd say um because it's
efficient its fishing I like it it
doesn't sound appetizing but oh really
it sounds very rare yeah okay yeah it's
got a little spicy flakes on there too
have you heard of cheated on us cuz I
feel like yeah it's skin though it's
good okay I'm nervous about that if you
find about what it is jump on these
people have turned off by it I know it
is something like a peppery mmm I like
that
that'll be weird for you or really you
like the taste I do like to say I would
love to have this as I would like going
camping or something like that yeah this
is like like a sweetness going on a
little spiciness going on okay yeah take
some time think happy thoughts
it's just chips mm-hmm but I can't get
the image out of like the pork skin yes
II bet this is really good
get on some of this it says great Pepe -
um I definitely had similar snacks like
this you like in Southeast Asia maybe
it's the same thing maybe same probably
I know it is this is just I feel like I
could Mexican this up really quick we
could get a taco and then put some of
that and then some of these give it like
a car to drive oh this one is saving me
from that dried is this really that
weird to you I don't know why I'm okay
with other kind of turkeys but not like
ish but fish for some reason maybe I
smell almost like I respect I mean I
love this too but you know for the sake
of culture exchange
I guess I'll prefer this more usually
than this mom I do like the crunchy
aspect of it I don't know like I don't
wanna sleep on this this is really good
green and Mexican food are not that
different
this is a like a kind of like they're
thinking in like the same boat like yeah
each snack kind of had like a scent very
similar vibe all those snacks kind of
share the same and suppose that's cuz
everyone likes savory stuff or one like
a fatty stuff one like sweet stuff it's
just like you're a different culture is
like
I guess the moral that I'm taking from
the appearances like it don't be afraid
to try new things the fish jerky I need
more time with that all right I want to
try it again but there's like you are
bold to try it though yeah
[Music]